nuggets 42 points in the third quarter
most since 2019
versus chicago pass under the cousins
and his cousin's travels
oh you gotta be careful that's his
technical and that's the second one he
slammed the ball and now boogie cousins
is out of the game
can't put the ball down unless you catch
it he had a technical earlier and
that'll mean nicole joking back in well
he got a tentacle early john was
somebody in the bench
so whoever that guy is down on the end
of the bench give him credit
[Applause]
so cousins is gone
and that's bad news and good news scott
hastings the bad news boogie's out and
he was playing well the good news is
that he's replaced by the most valuable
player in the nba yeah
but patty mills will shoot the technical
free throw
[Applause]
this has been a interesting this has
been a long 43 seconds
and mills misses the free throw
they are called traveling on boogie
you see lift to that right foot with his
pivot foot and watch him going to put
the ball down